the Star Wars films are starting to dig
a little deeper into the backstories of
its most popular characters starting
with a han Solo prequel that features
Alden Ehrenreich in the role originally
played by Harrison Ford if that sone is
successful enough it'll likely increased
interest in peeks at some of the other
characters past and who has a more
interesting history than princess leia
organa sure we got to see how her
parents got together during the Star
Wars prequel trilogy but there are a lot
of gods still to connect like who taught
her the secret Jedi are two-faced
insults I don't know where you get your
delusions laser brain the late great
Carrie Fisher unquestionably made the
role her own and left some big boots to
fill with her untimely passing in
December 2016
recasting Leia would be about more than
just tracking down a doppelganger for
Fisher the actress would have to have
some wits staff and class to offer to
here are a few young actresses who might
just be equipped to pick up the old
laughter and bring Leia back to life
Millie Bobby Brown stranger things
starlet Millie Bobby Brown has already
put her hat into the ring by declaring
that she'd love to play a young Princess
Leia in a prequel thanks to her breakout
role as 11 in Netflix's sci-fi sensation
Brown has already proven she can hold
her own in an onscreen sight and her
time on shows like ABC's once upon a
time had her grappling with a sort of
high fantasy and science fiction world
that any young Leia would encounter in a
new Star Wars movie
that means she's used to tackling tough
scripts filled with weird character
names and alien species from around the
galaxy I can't say demagog enough us
listening even better Browns got the
same brown eyes and hair as Leia along
with similar facial bone structure so
it's easy to picture her adopting a roll
without a hitch Rowan Blanchard another
young actress who looks like a ringer
for young Leia is Girl Meets World Star
Rowan Blanchard like brown Blanchard has
already had her fair share of high
action moments on screen thanks to her
turn in Spy Kids 4 and she's also one to
watch right now as she'll star in Ava
Duvernay live-action adaptation of a
wrinkle in time
giving her fantasy cred as well as a
major platform from which to launch her
film career the world
to me with an opportunity perhaps most
importantly Blanchard also seems to have
a youthful sense of wisdom and width
that would be an absolute necessity for
playing young Leia Mackenzie Foy she
might be best known for her work as a
half vampire love child in The Twilight
Saga final film but Mackenzie Foy has
also proven herself a capable young
talent on the rise she shared the screen
with Matthew McConaughey in Christopher
Nolan's interstellar and she has a lead
role in lasse hallström upcoming take on
the Nutcracker and the four realms in
much the way the young Carrie Fisher
carries herself with a sense of self
confidence and capability mixed with
softness joy has the same kind of steady
composure that could suit a new take on
the princess
Kiernan Shipka throughout Mad Men six
seasons
Kiernan Shipka grew into the secret MVP
of the series especially where its
youngest cast members were concerned
while the actor is playing her brother
Bobby came and went without much fuss
Shipka blossomed into an important
presence on the show as Sally sturdily
run encountered to her parents selfish
behavior before subtly adopting some of
their traits Shipka can not only deliver
a sharp tongued line like nobody's
business
you think he could take me I think I
could well you're wrong but she's also
able to impart nuance and curiosity to
situations to enrich a scene that might
otherwise fall flat a Princess Leia
backstory would need those traits in
abundance so she might just be a good
match for the movie Sophia Lilith she
might not be a household name just yet
but Sophia Lilith is also well on her
way to becoming an important young
actress she not only possesses the same
kind of stoicism that helped define Leia
on screen but she's also starring in the
new film adaptation of Stephen King's it
as the uncomfortable Beverly Marsh that
means she'll start to be on the star
track sooner than later
she's also another close visual ringer
for young Carrie Fisher a pair of brown
contacts and those signature cinnamon
bun locks are all it take to make the
transformation complete
of course as good as any of those
options to be there's really only one
young actress who could truly do the
role the Justice it deserves Billie
lourd the fact that Billie Lord is
Fisher's own daughter means she
certainly deserved more than a little
consideration from what we've seen of
her screen appearances in screen queens
and other roles she also seems to have
inherited Fisher's signature tenacity
and deep sense of humor Lord made a
cameo appearance in Star Wars The Force
awakens and told reporters I wish I
played a young princess who better to
manage her mother's legacy than Lord
plus let's face it she's Leia's closest
look-alike it's actually kind of spooky
how similar they are I try to do my own
thing but when I'm wearing something
like this is it kind of hard to escape
the comparison thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]